yes all right someone had a man named
alex added me on twitter on legendary
pictures account
and i guess got so excited i had to hop
on here right away to talk about it the
godzilla versus kong trailer
on legendary pictures is officially
announced to come out
this sunday so guys keep a look out
this sunday it should be up on youtube
keep a lookout for our reaction as well
but they put out this
really great poster um make sure i got
it pulled up
all right here it is right now you got
this photo here uh where
throughout the smoke it's the colors of
the franchises
the blue and red and it's obscuring kong
behind the city and it looks like just
classic king kong as he's towering over
these buildings
and then it says one will fall on it and
you've got godzilla popping out at the
bottom of frame here not his face
but that looks so photo real like looks
realistic it doesn't look like cgi but
this
image just gives me chills this is such
a great image
um this is a great great poster this is
the kind of poster i'd love to own and
put up on the wall over here sometime
oh what a great looking photo i love the
colors
i love just how imposing this feels we
have a podcast on patreon and someone
did ask a question of who we think will
win
uh i went into like great detail on this
podcast about who i think would win and
why
and i might post that later today just
take that excerpt out and oh man i
didn't even notice this man in my mind
how do i miss this on the right side
where it says
kong uh it looks like some of the
building is on fire
right behind the letter of kong and
that's what's creating the smoke that
makes a lot more sense now
yep i'm a little dumb oh they're going
to cause destruction and mayhem
i love how the side of godzilla's clean
even though it has the blue smoke
yet on kong's side it's on it feels like
it's on fire
i'm super excited for this and part of
this trailer though
i am really hoping it is not just a
combined
six seconds of the collective two
seconds
that we got over the last couple of
years this better not just be another
two more seconds
this has to be an official real trailer
i'm excited for this
guys keep a lookout subscribe hit that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction is up and tell me down
below
what you think of this poster i think it
looks phenomenal and
keep a lookout for a reaction